this late in Vanda rush is something
else and the Cowboys all of a sudden
with van der s and Jaylon Smith on the
defensive side of the balls for the hot
boys
they call themselves we're gonna see how
good they are in today and Amari Cooper
and Izzy Kelly it'd have been terrific
together with dak it's more of that
friendly situation in the voice of the
Dallas Cowboys Brad sham calls us in
advance of that huge week 13 kickoff on
Thursday night between the Saints the
Cowboys how are you Brad I'm all right
rich how are you did I set the table
appropriately I mean you are a first
your first is that van dress is good and
I'm looking forward to him and Leonard
being on the same field about three
people that's right they are you you're
going Indianapolis in week 15 with the
Cowboys let's get to this right here
right now I mean the conversation that
Cooper has changed so much because of
what he brought to the table just as a
mere threat and backing everybody up off
the line Jerry even said it was similar
to urban back in people up off the line
for for for Emmett and a lot of people
had their fun with that and guess what
then he goes for a buck 80 on
Thanksgiving is it is the the corner
turned on the offense in your mind Brad
oh let's not say that yet it's but
they're certainly better than they were
they did two things at once that was one
and then they made a change in the
offensive line coaching and promoted
mark Colombo and brought the Hudson Hawk
in to work with him as a consultant and
and Colombo's just got a completely
different attitude so he he had been
with them as the assistant line coach
and and and coincidentally to all that
Connor Williams the rookie left guard
suffered a knee injury and Xavier Susilo
who actually started a lot of games for
the Texans a couple of years ago but had
been on the street and they signed him
in September as a backup guard he'd been
inactive most of the year but he got
inserted into the lineup going into
Philadelphia because they needed a guard
and he's just bigger than Williams and
he I don't want to make him out to be
John Hannah but he's played pretty well
and so the whole thing has has come
together nicely but before you can say a
corner has been turned they've got to do
a few more but they're back in the
conversation now it's going to be it has
the appearance of being whatever happens
Thursday night should be a meaningful
December and that beats the alternative
of what it looked like at the halfway
point yeah I mean where everyone thought
this is the end for Garrett I mean this
is the absolute how does he handle all
that because he seems to be at the most
sunny disposition whenever I'm around
him and and and none of this seems to
affect him I'm wondering what you see on
the day-to-day here Brett you know it
doesn't it that as as much as it can not
affect a human being he he literally
does not have a social media presence
nor does his wife that I'm aware of
so anything that said on social media
which is the nastiest stuff
although the newspapers have been a
little unkind but anything on social
media he someone's literally got to
bring it to it and that would happen
like once and I think they all hear and
read what is said on the airwaves and
what's written in the newspapers but he
is so focused that he's he's intent on
and they make fun of him rich for saying
our job today
at the best Tuesday we can except today
they're trying to have the best Friday
they can right because because it's
Friday and football week with a Thursday
night game but he yeah I don't think
that stuff bothers him I can't say that
doesn't influence him he understands the
sense of urgency and I think that's at
the heart of some of the changes they've
made but it it doesn't he's not worried
about whether he's gonna lose his job or
well then then take me a little bit
further into this situation Brad cuz to
continue the conversation through the
social media prism essentially everybody
likes having fun that he just stands
there and claps
and just roots that Iman like he's got
pom-poms what does he do he let fans
know what he does day-in day-out
GameDay what what what does he do to
affect success for the Cowboys
one thing he does similar to the guy he
played for here Jimmy Johnson is set the
tone and he actually does like to
micromanage a little bit but not when it
comes to his staff so he will give
coordinators and position coaches a lot
of rope and sometimes maybe too much but
he is the one who as Jimmy did and I'm
not comparing him to Jimmy I'm just
saying I know that Jimmy did that
probably as well as anyone besides
Parcells who's been here in a long time
and that is to say this is on Monday
this is what the message is going to be
this week and you knew what it was
because by Wednesday all the players
were saying that and that's what these
guys do and he is really good at setting
them as is absolute best in moments of
crisis when he took over when Wade
Phillips was fired after they're going
once after they've done one in seven in
2010 they finished five and three that
was a moment of crisis for the team and
he redirected their focus immediately a
few years but they had the tragedy of a
practice squad player being killed in a
car wreck the night before a road game
with one of his teammates at the wheel
he redirected their focus and they won
the next day and they stay there head
stayed in the game and so he he has
thought through the first half of the
year that they weren't being as
aggressive as he wanted them to be I
think he's asserted himself a little bit
more at directing the message and and
that's what he does he is very hands on
but not in a not in a way that that
intrudes not with with every aspect of
the team he'll sit in on every meeting
special teams defensive backs or he'll
sit in on all of them but not in a way
that's intrusive but he is he is really
involved in every ass
of it and it I can't speak for other
organizations but I know it hasn't
always been that way with every head
coach this team has ever had and the
thing that people don't understand and
it boggles my mind is that the and it's
not just here but the head coach who you
see at the press conference and who you
see on the sidelines is not necessarily
the guy who his players see in meetings
and that's the guy that's important but
the guy who's at the press conferences
is the guy that Twitter's reacting to
here and the fans don't like the fact
that Garrett is even healed publicly all
the time and I will tell you that his
public role models as well as coaching
are Bill Belichick and Nick Saban and
he's told me but I asked him once
because I've known him since he was a
rookie here I asked him watch why why
did you not you know give him a little
bit more at the press conference
you know Belichick's got a great
philosophy about that which is hey how's
that gonna help me with I I need I need
to manage the message control the
message and I don't need to I don't need
to win a battle of a press conference I
need to get my team ready to play and so
it's intentional that he is not more
filled with bubbling personality at
press conferences and that's not who he
is and the the the clapping thing just
boggles my mind that's what people
people have glommed on to that and and
it's ridiculous
yeah the clapper that's his nickname
breath yes I think yeah I don't have her
boys underscore Vox on Twitter Brad Jam
40th season brought 40 seasons brought a
broadcasting Dallas Cowboys football
Layton Vander who does he compared to
two kids that you've seen come out well
over the decades the the the thing that
people said when he came out of the
draft was Urlacher and that's the best
comparison I can think of was of size
and range I can't say he's Urlacher sure
right but if you say when you see the
guy running and playing and tackle
covering and who does that look like to
you if you took all that all the
insignias and the numbers off doesn't
look like anybody they've had here
because he's bigger than Shawn Lee I and
I said last I said at the beginning of
this year actually the Jaylon Smith if
he kept going was going to be the most
explosive linebacker the Cowboys had had
since Thomas Henderson was a very young
player and Vander Esch actually has that
kind of explosion but we didn't see it
in the summer because he missed the
entire preseason so we thought it was
good but he was injured and we didn't
know what we were looking at until we
started to see it and he's just grown by
leaps and bounds and he does look like
Urlacher playing and you can see why
people have made that comparison if he
has that good a career obviously then
then they've done pretty well yeah I
mean they got two guys and we're all
over the field in the linebacker
position I mean him and James Smith are
absolutely everywhere sideline to
sideline Brandon Brad and then you got
those guys up front the so-called hot
boys who are really bringing the heat
now a goat there's no question a goat at
the highest perhaps level of play that
Drew Brees has ever had I mean he's just
putting the putting balls in Windows so
tight and everybody's catching
everything and chimera and Ingram are
dynamite what what do you think the
chances are here and what are they the
Cowboys need to do to come up with the
win in your estimation Thursday you know
I may be the obvious answer is so you're
telling me there's a chance it's more
than dumb and Dumberer I'm sure but I
would I would say to you that I don't
see how they're gonna do it had I not
seen in 2009 when the Saints coached by
the same head coach and quarterback by
the same quarterback yep at home home on
a Saturday night thirteen at old hynden
Walch at uh Dallas Dallas goes in eighth
and five with DeMarcus Ware having been
carted off the field with the neck
injury the previous Sunday and didn't
know he was gonna play literally until
they got in the locker room that night
and Dallas came out very aggressive on
offense in the in the
superdome hit him right in the mouth and
played with him toe-to-toe all night and
won the game so I saw that so I'd be an
idiot to say it can't happen I cannot
stand here and tell you I know how it's
gonna happen Thursday night because
you're right drew brees is playing at as
high a level right now as I don't know
if I've ever seen anyone play at a
higher level Brady's had great years
Aaron Rodgers has been phenomenal if
Drew Brees right now cannot make a
mistake if he tries he doesn't catching
it four touchdowns to undrafted rookies
I'm not sure he'd met them all he's he
is at the very top level so I mean the
formula is you have to get after him you
have to make him uncomfortable it's very
hard to second you have to make him
uncomfortable you have to cover at the
back end they're going to have to
plaster and then when you have the ball
you have to be who you are very
aggressive use your running back
dominate the ball and score at the end
of it and shorten the game and that's
the formula whether they can do it or
not I don't know but the Saints are
pretty good but they're gonna try we
were that was the NFL Network coverage
of that Saturday night game Brad I'll
never forget we had Jerry Jones on our
pregame show and as you know he only
knows one speed when having a
conversation on the air and he just
flat-out said I'm as nervous as a cat
because he he I think the implication
was and we all sensed it that had they
lost that game he would have had to fire
Wade right then in there and he didn't
want to do it and as you know he didn't
he didn't do it until was one in seven
the next year you know and so that was
amazing because that place was lit it
was a weekend game it was a night game
you know so there was no blue flu needed
to take a day off in New Orleans people
would spent the whole day lubricating if
you will for the game it was so loud
that night and they won that football
game it was unreal and the Saints by the
way lost all their remaining games that
year went into the postseason won the
Superbowl anyway as incredible yeah
exactly right and the Cowboys won their
division and won a playoff game one of
- the Garrett's one as the head coach
but you know they're there they're six
and five now they were eight and five
then and the the the parallels are
similar I actually asked Garrett if it
was helpful to him to have watched any
of that game or were the Saints two
different and he said that he said the
personnel and the schemes are different
enough that you wouldn't necessarily get
anything from it but the approach is
that they took that night that was
successful not the tactics necessarily
but the but the psychological approach
is what they're gonna have to have to be
able to play with Brad love our chats
thanks again have a great test on
Thursday let's chat again soon thanks
rich look forward to as always that's
Brad sham the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience